hey what's up folks it's basketball
season NBA 2k16 is out and of course
that means that once again Mary is
asking us to sit in front of a Kinect
the scan our ugly mugs into this video
game so let's get to it I guess
alrighty all I have to do is hit okay
and Here I am no more time come on mine
dummy Mitch doesn't open my mouth Mary
sighs is that it would be all take all
right I feel like I didn't do enough I
feel like that was too easy
like it's I like to barely turn my face
left and Ryan it was like yeah we got it
it's looking a little moving like that
if my face melting which is great cuz
I'm really terrible at basketball this
is gonna be wonderful Escape is
induction see why I can make myself like
six foot nine as well
presumably it automatically makes me an
african-american man yeah great
what what's wrong with my butt I've got
like this Carlos Tevez style burn thing
happening here what's your tongue what
the way I've got these eyes it's like
I'm haunted by my it's like I had like a
twin embryo that then like died on my
face before I was born
Ashida black
fines our staff a strong work ethic Amy
check out the rocky bill eclectic a
little when I say 18 seconds Rangers of
ratchet have been upgraded paid he
doesn't benefit I've got more chip I'm
gonna sign for the kiss-off the contrack
star no we'll have fun out for the kid
out for the kid no mr. play the showers
this one I sprayed on your mark stocks
kid when I say I'm I'm ready heavy like
a wheel you're talking [ __ ] your
mom's telling I just went back to the
car back off
Oh painting this finish its leaves and
chase these two minutes you watch the
coach but with the toss make you lost
your mind
but there's not enough time to get your
typical watch
gosh there's no time
you watch
guitars Ticketmaster
I know
is not enough time
it's not enough enough typical you watch
the coach but the toss we can blast a
mine I wanna get it all down but there's
not enough time
I'm going to send my parents a picture
like mati boy in the NBA
oh you can get like more in depth if you
wanted to it I haven't done this before
and I guess according to some people it
looks like you but I've never seen that
guy oh well have like almost like a
conehead going on or something yeah it
could be better I feel like it's still
better than Danny's death I can't
complain mouthing off your smile show
off get bill is on with your mom I'm
trying to pick the time so much [ __ ] to
stop it's like a nomad Rick spinning
my own glass aligning screen never wind
a frenzy so hard to get ready pick your
color get your divisions in a minute